it mostly between shard who makes
well we so the active discussion first
dave built in the west and balkans
it's clear told it that insite and
outsite is stuck trying to death to
listen you how to knifen
that's where leaders wie fda nico poco's
apart  for the side knew in the west and
balkans and she the european perspective
he hopes dispositifs i took from the yo
how that skin in the way and now you have the
dewi with the twenty five and it
the usa section on this video found that
years multispeed europe would be one of
the discussions it at the roma level
sorry hai understand the reasons for
this however confit the ring the interest
of the community of 20 seven countries in
the context of the upcoming brexit
négociations
and women is the longest and street that  your
child is there or the you a we being have
we to strive towards my tank
politicaly unity and make the 20
occasionally database he can open so
lead to a twentieth of dj
grievous the subjection  f the salt and ex
apps